of all the things you've worked on what
ended up being the toughest shot that
you did on one of these sets the one
that just really you know what I mean
the one whether it be camera moves
whether it be
um whatever it may be that's a that's a
really good question and weirdly I think
even though it's not a single shot it's
a sequence and I love the sequence and I
would do it again in a heartbeat uh but
physically the most enduring
um it's so much of an endurance race was
a mission impossible helicopter sequence
uh because it was so extremely cold
um literally above the Southern Alps in
winter with the doors open on a
helicopter and I'm sticking my face into
the wind and firing blanks with all
sorts of stuff lying back at me and just
doing it over and over and over again
completely deaf just waiting for the
pilot to scream something inaudible and
do this which meant we're rolling and so
I had to then just keep on acting with
my head out the window until I assumed
that they had stopped shooting and so I
was watching either Tom's helicopter in
front or behind and watching the camera
ship as well to see when the camera ship
kind of pulled away and did its own
thing and I was like okay I think that
means I can sit back in now and I'll do
that for 40 minutes then land and then
sit by a little uh like red rat heater
War my hands up and within half an hour
they're like right we're refueled let's
go again and it was just having to to
suck it up and do that for I think it
was
at least two weeks
um but that was that was rough but I
absolutely love the sequence and it was
so worth it there's nothing worse than
spending all of your energy and time and
heart and soul trying to do something
and the other ingredients aren't there
but on a Mission Impossible movie
I mean all the ingredients are there and
so it was such a pleasure to do